their last holiday to tenerife feels
like a distant memory
when travel was unrestricted and no one
had even heard of covid19
when the pandemic hit lee bromley and
his housemate meg
thought they'd be safe to book a holiday
in 2021
they were supposed to be there now but
have already had to postpone until march
and are worried that's now in doubt it's
very disappointing i've saved up all the
holiday from work so i'm going to lose
21 days holiday
from my job because i i'm not going away
or anything now
um mental health wise i i love the
sunshine i love to have a break
i just need to get away and get some
sunshine just to cheer me up
if you did have to pay to quarantine
when you got back
would you be able to afford it another
10 days and possibly 1500 pounds
just too much in this the bleakest of
winters
foreign travel feels a very long way off
in uk holiday destinations like here in
the cotswolds they're preparing for a
very
different kind of summer one where in
all likelihood there'll be far
fewer visitors from abroad but a surge
in demand from
brits who don't want to risk booking a
foreign holiday
the owner of this lakeside holiday let
important on the water usually takes
more than
half her bookings from foreign tourists
this is our
one-bedroom modern holiday
but this year they've all cancelled have
you seen an increase in enquiries from
british people
yes it's definitely shifted to mainly
british people
but even if they could go abroad later
on in the year
they're nervous about it because of
trying to get their money back whereas
they know that if they can travel in the
uk
virtually everybody is given a full
refund
should situation change across the uk
it's a similar story with demand for
staycation
so high some places are booking up
if you already know what you want and
you're already looking you know you're
going to find in certain locations that
there's not going to be that
availability in particular in july and
august
that you once had with everyone now
taking that uk break
with a government announcement imminent
on quarantine hotels for uk arrivals
many are now pinning their hopes on a
great british summer
in winter lockdown even that feels a
long way away
becky johnson sky news in the cotswolds